what is hypertension hypertension often
abbreviated as HTN is the medical term
for high blood pressure which of course
is dangerous talk about why in just a
second but normally our blood pressure
is considered to be 120 over 80 or
that's the normal value that people
shoot for or talk about as being normal
this top number is the systolic value
and the bottom number is the diastolic
value and the top number is basically
the highest blood pressure in the
arteries it's basically when your heart
is contracting and the diastolic one is
when your heart is relaxed so it's the
lower pressure the range though for
normal blood pressure as it has not all
not all people will have one exactly 120
over 80 for the blood pressure the
typical normal range is 100 to 139
millimeters of mercury over sixty to
seventy nine millimeters or seamy sixty
to eighty nine millimeters of mercury so
this is considered to be the normal
range sometimes people say that anything
from 120 up to 139 or from 80 to 89 is
considered pre-hypertensive it than
everything below 120 over 80 would be
considered normal
but generally speaking this is the
normal range but if you go beyond that
that'd be considered high blood pressure
so you have a high blood pressure if the
systolic value is greater than or equal
to 140 or the diastolic value is greater
than equal to 90 and this can be an end
or here so a systolic value of 140 or
higher is high blood pressure a
diastolic value of 90 or higher is high
blood pressure and both together would
be high blood pressure as well there are
two classes of hypertension and they're
based on the cause the first one is
primary or essential hypertension and
the second one is secondary
primary or essential hypertension is
when there's really no clear or obvious
underlying medical cause for the
hypertension where a secondary is caused
by other conditions that affect the
kidney arteries heart or the endocrine
system and most often secondary
hypertension is due to renal disease
which is diseases of the kidneys
now most cases of hypertension are
primary hypertension about 90 to 95
percent are primary hypertension where
there's no clear underlying cause and
secondary makes up about five to ten
percent of those case that 10 percent of
the other cases as far as primary
essential hypertension goes age genetics
and environment are all factors that
sort of seem to be contributing to
primary hypertension but why is
hypertension so bad the reason why is
that hypertension puts a continued
strain on the heart and arteries in your
body and that is bad because that causes
damage to those organs and that's the
reason that's bad damage to these organs
is bad because we need our
cardiovascular system in order to
survive and if the harder arteries are
damaged then actively do a bunch of
different things including heart disease
stroke and aneurysms which all shortened
life expectancy which is not something
we want if you want to live long happy
lives so we want to prevent hypertension
how do we know if we have hypertension
what are the symptoms and how is it
diagnosed it's interesting because
hypertension most of the time there are
no symptoms most of time there are no
symptoms
and that's interesting so hypertension
is kind of silent it's sneaky on rare
occasions there are some symptoms that
I've outlined here the ones that are
bracketed in blue can just be due to
anxiety or even stress or maybe even
some other condition or disease and
these pink ones are the ones that are
highlighted in this prac this uh pink
bracket here can if they do exist and
they are due to hypertension they can be
malignant hypertension which is
basically a hypertensive emergency and
that would need to be treated
immediately
but generally speaking there are no
symptoms so how is this diagnosed well
if you go to get your blood pressure
measured healthcare professionals use
this thing called a sphygmomanometer
which is manometer I definitely spelled
that incorrectly sphygmomanometer
which is a fancy term for a blood
pressure cuff which they wrap around
your arm and they pump it up and they
also use a stethoscope to listen to the
blood flow through your arteries and
they might take your blood pressure
let's say you run to the hot to your
doctor's office and you're getting a
blood pressure measured and you just
came in from running and you get a blood
pressure of 142 over 92 that would be
considered high blood pressure but one
reading is not enough to diagnose high
blood pressure because maybe the maybe
the fact that you ran to the office
elevated your blood pressure sometimes
people are even stressed when they go to
see a healthcare professional and that
can increase their blood pressure the
stress itself and so sometimes it's
actually called white coat hypertension
in which people go to the just to a
healthcare professional or a doctor and
they get their blood pressure measured
and it's high simply because they went
and they're stressed so what ends up
happening and is in order to diagnose
this we need to
find out whether the blood pressure
readings are consistent so the diagnosis
is based on persistently high blood
pressure readings in fact typically
there are three readings taken each one
month apart and if they all happen to be
140 over 90 or hypertensive in either
case systolic or diastolic at that point
hypertension can be diagnosed and when
it is diagnosed there are there can
there can be tests run including a urine
test or blood tests or glucose test and
or even an EKG electrocardiogram and
these things would be ordered in order
to rule out potential underlying
conditions which would classify the
hypertension as secondary hypertension
so how do we prevent hypertension how do
we prevent this bad thing
it's actually pretty simple all we have
to do is make healthy lifestyle choices
healthy lifestyle choices and this of
course includes eating healthy foods so
those healthy foods things like fruits
and veggies and whole grains and lean
meats low-fat dairy basically less sugar
fat and salt which brings me to my next
point here lower salt intake so a lower
salt intake and greatly help with
producing the risk for high blood
pressure another thing of course is
maintaining a healthy weight for your
your height is important in order to
prevent hypertension increasing physical
activity whether that's walking more
running more playing a sport increasing
physical activity can greatly help
cardiovascular health limiting alcohol
consumption of course can help prevent
pretention quitting smoking and not
smoking just in general is essential to
prevent hypertension and something that
may not be mentioned too often is
managing stress if you manage stress and
that can actually help lower your blood
pressure so if you can just be happy and
smile you might be happy and healthier
another thing if you do is monitor your
own blood pressure at home and kind of
keep track of it and if you see that it
might be going up a little bit you can
take the the other things into account
and maybe begin to manage your blood
pressure on your own so take your health
into your own hands and prevent
hypertension from perhaps getting to you
that's about it thank you for watching